Rishi I thought this game is going to be
over uh two three hours ago what just
happened
I kind of shared your
ideas and enthusiasm also about the game
finishing very quickly no I yeah I don't
know in the opening I kind of forgot to
play for I think I played this at one
point I guess Hitler
um yeah he's surprised you with this
idea and I this have a night before game
against Switzerland against Peter in a
singfield cup
some years ago and I think I played A4
at some point but I couldn't recall it
instantly or necessary
and yeah it was the same thing actually
but then he went
um somehow Knight F6 and queen D7 after
Queen D3 Series yeah I think this is
maybe a bit better for white I had a
feeling but obviously if a4a5 included
it I would have been a better structure
if it would help your cause you have
some Bishop to maybe attack the uh yeah
it's like after when I play um B3 C4
like in the in the extremely Far Far
Future the structure is just simply more
present so I thought you know I went for
this cute idea with Knight F4 I was
quite happy about this but then um right
away after H6 I I kind of missed I think
I should have just captured F6 and queen
B3 maybe some slight pressure with this
opposite colored Bishops playing for C4
deck in a decade or something yeah and
then Queen E7 was played and
here yeah my original idea was to take
on F6
obviously but here almost whatever
reason uh yeah that's that's an
impossible move to make
it there we go okay yeah Queen takes A3
and um Bishop G7 King G7 ba3 and you
know the problem is yeah whatever the
point is that the Knight is arriving and
I'm not on time to to create anything
and then I decided okay I will at least
have a rest day
um yeah and that's what we thought as
well we thought that we're going to
interview uh you uh two hours ago after
a draw yeah exactly and then it was very
I mean he missed um he was he got
careless obviously because he fought
everything he's a joke I mean you know
the good news is that he has this double
pawns so
um B3 is quite amazing so like I'm not
at risk at all and he wanted to you know
probably wrap the game up very quickly
with yeah A4 B5 idea and he missed
obviously uh Bishop takes D1
um I mean when you saw B5 did you
understand that you're starting to get
some chances yeah I mean I saw this as
like my kind of last trick uh obviously
I don't know if I guess maybe still a
drawing I don't think I don't know if
it's winning provide or not yeah but it
was quite clear to me that he he wanted
to stop the Rooks and play before and
and liquidate yeah and that was quite um
okay I'm not saying I was quite proud
but you know like Bishop takes D1 is a
nice move to make and obviously he kind
of missed it based on his speed of you
know playing B5 quite quickly and before
and yeah this end game I thought maybe
he should have gone for a four here but
I'm not so sure if uh I think this was
the computer so yeah this is a draw or
this is lost already but like take and
G5 right it felt like yeah first it felt
like a better um
but you know this is super desperate
um I mean this this kind of effort yeah
and um it could be just that he is just
losing so obviously it's very hard
psychological this type of situations
ever happened to you and what are those
emotions when you realize okay I'm not
finishing the game anytime soon I'm
actually going to be tortured for the
next two three hours yeah sometimes it
was on the receiving end of things
sometimes I was you know like today
um beneficiary of these these changes
it's not not a good feeling to have
obviously if you're um you know in
trouble yeah but at the end of the day
this is uh this is the game and if you
know I I learned them
something from a you know my recent
experience and with the guys on the
highest level that the game is basically
um somehow never over here until it's
over so you have to be you have to be
careful yeah
it's not not a you know not my proudest
moment obviously to win this game even
afterwards obviously it's a great deal
but you know yeah sometimes it happens
sometimes you get lucky yeah this way so
I obviously take the win I don't know if
I missed something from knowing myself
it's very like I think at some point
maybe you let him back in the game but
yeah it could have been yeah I I didn't
it's very unclear the engine yeah I
didn't see for him exact draw but at
some point he came up with this very
clear clear creative this was the moment
so after Bishop to H3 King B6 and then
we Shuffle the pieces a bit oops excuse
me
and you played this move
King to E6 Bishop to F1
and then after you uh grab the second
pawn bishop to D4 take on F5 and now
King to E7 instead
actually I wasn't sure I thought it's
really in King A4 King A4 King d8 and
now King yes the same same idea not
Bishop G4 I thought this is just doing I
mean and then A5
and if H3 I have E5 Bishop f4h3 my
Bishop goes to fh5 I provoke F6 C5 and
then King g45 I break here I felt like
it's kind of a reasonable sequence and
perhaps this is what he was worried
about as well yeah it's a Pawn on H4
sometimes there are these issues here
like just put the bishop to D5 Pawn to
C5 and then King to G4 yeah C6 actually
doesn't matter if I didn't see at least
maybe maybe I'm missing something but uh
yeah it felt like
yeah like I said it could be that I'm
missing something you know it could be
that his King is fast I don't know yeah
uh even so he was falling down on time
as well he was having huge problems with
his time at this point a lot of pressure
and uh you were able to take the full
point home this is an encouraging sign
for you and an encouraging start to the
tournament as well how are you feeling
right now I'm not really encouraging you
know I mean the game should have any
Infinity movement but yeah certainly a
nice feeling to to start with a certain
plus one you know let's say
um
I mean I cleared it on the Surplus found
out of these two games but you know
sometimes things happen that you don't
deserve one way or another so you take
it this is life yes congratulations
Richie we'll see you tomorrow
Christians